welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman gives us a riddler
pulled from our own gruesome history
with his own cryptic language of glyphs
inspired by the zodiac both david
fincher's 2007 film and the real-life
california serial killer who since i
moved to the bay area i intend to find i
don't buy those case breakers claims
from last october i think the real
zodiac is still out there and i will
find him or be found by him and as a
self-described robert greysmith of clues
and nerdy movies here on youtube i have
been all in on the cipher of paul dano's
riddler and matt reeves the batman
teased throughout all of its marketing
for the past year and a half and finally
as this movie releases we have just
about fully completed his alphabet so
here we go the full riddler cipher
explain
now most of this video will avoid
spoilers for the batman but there was a
last minute update to the cipher upon
the movie's release that i gotta mention
but i will put that at the very end of
the video and i will warn you when it's
coming up to tell you when to stop
watching so don't worry i got your back
the first riddler clue that we saw was
in the batman's first trailer all the
way back in august 2020. from your
secret friend who
having a clue let's play a game just me
and you inside that card the riddler
left the riddle what does a liar do when
he's dead with the answer to the riddle
being a three-word cipher that we
translated to he lies still now right
away i looked at this and recognized the
parallels to zodiac the greeting card
with the skeleton on the cover looks
almost exactly like the card the zodiac
actually mailed to san francisco
chronicle reporter paul avery and the
technique that we used to decode he lies
still was the same double consonant
technique from code breaking 101 which
in david fincher's zodiac film robert
gray smith explicitly cites two paul
avery what's the most common double
consonant in the english language
consonant the double l and what's the
one word that we know that he'll use in
here at least once
right kill so the hard start looking for
double symbols which they find here here
and here each with the same two symbols
preceding them so now they've got a
repeating four-letter word ending with
two symbols that they assume stand for l
since i think the whole word is kill and
you got the k you got your eye and
you're on your way so this reference
actually gives us a road map to how to
complete the rest of the riddler's
alphabetic cipher he lies still gave us
our first six letters e h i l s t then
in october 2021 and the marketing for
the film now included another five-word
riddler cipher the most common phrase
that appears on various posters and
standees for the film that translates to
you are el rata aladda el rata a lotta
spanish translating to you are the
winged rat and that gives us another
wave of six letters to continue filling
in this alphabet a d o r u and y really
el rata a lotta turned out to be a super
important thematic core for the batman
in all kinds of ways specifically as the
title of a promotional website where
additional ciphers were unlocked by
answering riddler riddles the first of
these was an image for the riddler's
question mark logo surrounded by hatch
marks three of these hatch marks
composed of glyphs that translated to
stay and vigilant so this one gave the
overall cipher three more letters g n
and v then an update to the site on
january 27th unlocked another cipher
with four words translating to more will
be revealed which gave us b m and w then
another update on january 30th revealed
another four word cipher translating to
expose more of gotham which gave us
three more letters f p and x now pause
in here because i found this wording to
be suspect expose more of gotham just
some weird semantics there like why
would the riddler consider part of
gotham 2 already be exposed and now say
expose more of it like you would think
he would just say expose gotham right
that's his whole mo so assuming these
phrases have been released strategically
with some kind of wordle mentality each
new phrase including three new letters
that we didn't have before it really
does seem like they included the words
more of so that we would now be able to
add f to the grid and i do think this
was intentional because literally every
release after this included only one new
letter at a time a new set of posters
for the film on february 6th included a
three-word cipher translating to unmask
the truth from which we got one new
letter the letter k the next cipher on
february 18th had two words that
translated to enough questions giving us
one more new letter a nice juicy
10-point scrabble title of q and then on
february 25th another three-word cipher
translating to come back soon which gave
us one new letter the letter c there's
no cooler way to level up in 2022 than
to become a lord or lady established
titles is the project based on a
historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english they let
people buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so they can call
themselves a lord or a lady and in
return establish titles commits to
planting a tree it's a really fun way to
help preserve the beautiful woodlands
and biodiversity of scotland while
raising funds to support global
conservation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
roots your title packs give you a
numbered plot of dedicated land on
private estate in ardele aberdeen shire
scotland and an official certificate
with a crest become a lord or lady of
scotland with established titles using
the code new rockstars to get an
additional 10 percent off just go to
establishtitles.comrockstars to get your
gifts now and then finally upon this
movie's release the site updated again
so that answering the riddles gives you
a zip file containing this video of
thomas wayne's mayoral campaign video
doctored by the riddler instilled in
both of us
the giving back is not just an
obligation
it's a passion
that is our family's legacy
[Music]
yeah interestingly tagged with hush in
there i will go into that more in the
breakdown but then also released was
another cipher with letters written out
in a bendy path translating to maze of
riddles so that gives us our z and
resulting in a total of 25 out of 26
letters leaving out conspicuously j and
i gotta point this out these were
revealed in a logarithmically descending
order of six then six then three then
three then three then one and one then
one and then one more coincidence
possibly i mean did the batman
production hire someone to count how
many new letters were revealed in the
first riddler clue that showed up in the
august 2020 trailer and then after that
craft specific phrases revealing letters
in a specific order if not warner
brothers disney sony hire me i am a
scrabble junkie that has forced the new
rockstar staff to join me in a wordle
channel every morning and my weird brain
is only useful as long as people still
go to youtube for nerd trivia i mean i
can't keep up with those babies on tick
tock okay now a major spoiler here for
those who have not yet seen the batman
really if that's you you really should
just stop watching this video pause it
come back later once you've seen the
movie like if you haven't seen the movie
yet and if you really care about
spoilers trust me pause right here i
appreciate you watching i'll see you
once you've seen the movie okay everyone
here's seen the movie now okay yeah it
seems like the letter j was deliberately
left out of the riddler cipher as a clue
for the friend the riddler makes in
arkham asylum in one of the final scenes
in the movie barry killen playing a role
credited as unseen arkham prisoner but
referring to himself as a clown in a
laugh and a disfigured face unmistakably
that of mr j the joker but we shouldn't
be that surprised the joker showed up in
this movie barry killen was heavily
speculated to be playing the joker in
the movie also warner's never gonna have
a batman without a joker in that
universe but also it sounds like it's
not just gonna be him and the riddler in
batman's future because they may also be
joined by mr freeze and matt reeves
cited a grounded mr freeze as a good
idea for a sequel villain so if there is
a plan to reveal these names in the form
of a riddler cipher at some point here
is the wordle block lineup to be on the
lookout for joker would look like this
in riddlery's
[Music]
so close and then freeze would look like
this in riddles
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
vos follow new rockstars subscribe to
the rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
batman
[Music]
you